[Music]
welcome back to harbor unboxed today
we're checking out sapphire's new
nitro plus radeon rx 6800 xt and i am
very keen to check this thing out
given that the 5700 xt version was one
of the best models we came across
and there are a number of changes here
when compared to the previous 5700 and
vega series nitro plus models so without
wasting any more time let's take a close
look at the card tear it down and then
get into some benchmark results
okay so in terms of dimensions this is
quite a long graphics card measuring 310
millimeters long and that means it
stretches 17
longer than the amd reference model it
also stands 134 millimeters tall making
it around 12 percent taller and it's
also 12 percent wider at 55 millimeters
so it will take up three expansion slots
so given that the nitro plus is
physically quite a bit larger than the
reference model you'd probably expect it
to weigh more as well
but it actually doesn't rather this
large graphics card
only weighs in at 1230 grams and that's
quite surprising given its size
the reference card for example weighs in
at 1510 grams and that means the
sapphire version
is 19 lighter so that is quite
surprising to discover
now sapphire says that they're focused
on refining the heat pipe and fin design
of the rx 6800 xt nitro plus and as a
result it is quite a bit lighter than
past
models they gave the example of their
vega 64 nitro plus which featured
a 1580 gram heatsink
so that's not the total card weight that
was the weight of just the heatsink
and for comparison the new heatsink on
the 6800 xt nitro plus
that weighs in at just 775 grams
so basically half the weight and this is
made all the more impressive when you
realize vega 64
and the 6800 xt feature the same board
power rating
that means they've been able to halve
the weight of the cooler on a card that
uses the same amount of power
while also reducing the operating volume
at least that is what sapphire's
claiming
design wise the 6800xt nitro plus looks
fairly similar to the 5700xt version
though there are a few obvious changes
firstly the fans have been
redesigned and look remarkably similar
to the axial tech fans from asus
they feature a very similar ring design
though sapphire has added some slots to
the 100 millimeter outer fans which
rotate counter-clockwise
meanwhile the centrally located 90mm fan
spins in a clockwise direction
the fan shroud has been constructed
using plastic but it looks quite good
and features
the typical nitro plus silver highlights
as
for rgb lighting most of the flashy
stuff can be found on the outer edge
there's some backlit sapphire branding
and a thin
light bar then around on the back side
of the card we find a full-length silver
backplate with
a backlit nitro logo i have to say
though the backplate does look really
nice and it even includes a few cutouts
that help aid with airflow
then finally before we tear down the
card let's take a quick look at the i o
panel
it's a pretty standard configuration
really what we're looking at here is a
single hdmi 2.1 port
and three displayport 1.4 outputs
okay so enough looking around the card
time to tear it down after removing a
series of screws from the back side of
the card the main cooler can now be
removed
the primary heatsink with the three fans
and plastic shroud weighing at just 668
grams
that's incredibly light it is designed
to cool just the gpu though
while a second much smaller heatsink
will capture airflow from the main
heatsink
to cool the vrm and gddr6 components
and this is a very similar design to
what we saw with the 5700xt nitrox model
and again it worked
very well there ensuring cool operating
temperatures for all the critical
components
but getting back to the primary heatsink
for a moment here we find a small copper
base plate which connects to half a
dozen
six millimeter thick nickel plated
copper heat pipes which disperse heat
through three separate banks of
aluminium fins
now the smaller cooler which is really
just a series of smaller heat sinks
connected to a heat spreader featuring
two low profile heat pipes
anyway it's a neat bit of kit that
directly cools the gddr6 memory along
with the power stages and
inductors then over on the 260
millimeter long pcb we find a robust vrm
packing
16 power stages along with a pair of
8-pin pcie power connectors
and a dual bios switch now for the power
stages
sapphire is using infineon's tda-21472
optimos power stages which are rated for
a 70 amp capacity
13 of which have been used to deliver
power to the gpu
11 for the gfx and 2 for the soc
then in addition to that there's a
single phase for the gpu power
v ddci and two phases for the gddr6
memory
finally on the rear side of the pcb we
find just a single thermal pad which has
been used to remove built up heat from
the back side of the vrm
or at least the vrm components located
on the right side of the board
i had expected to find more thermal pads
here but obviously sapphire has deemed
that unnecessary
still it is good to see that some heat
is being transferred to the aluminium
backplate
now in terms of clock specifications
sapphire lists a boost frequency of 2
360 megahertz which is a 5 increase over
the 2
250 megahertz default spec set by amd
the gddr6 memory on the other hand that
has been left stock at 16 gigabits per
second
when compared to other factory oc
graphics cards a 5
overclock is pretty mild so it will be
interesting to see how much oc headroom
is left
playing shut off the tomb raider for 30
minutes saw the nitro plus peak at 73
degrees in a 21 degree room inside the
corset obsidian 500d
fully populated with fans that's just
two degrees cooler than the amd
reference card
though do keep in mind power consumption
has increased by about 13
and the fan speed is also slightly
reduced so
quite a good result really speaking of
the fan speed in order to maintain this
temperature the fans spun at just
1500 rpm which is a very low fan speed
the typical core clock frequency seen
during our testing was 2
365 megahertz and that saw the power
consumption for the graphics card hit
336 watts so a 13
increase over the amd reference model
now for overclocking with the limits
reached we again saw a peak operating
temperature of 73 degrees but this time
the fans spun up to 1700 rpm
though even here they were remarkably
quiet and couldn't be heard over the
case fans
the overclock saw the cores operate at
an incredible 2560 megahertz on average
and their memory also hits 17.2 gigabits
per second
which is the current limit enforced by
amd
finally whenever clocked the card sucked
down 364 watts so an 8
increase from the stock factory oc
configuration
okay so let's move on to the benchmark
graphs as usual be testing with our amd
ryzen 9 3950x gpu test rig with 32
gigabytes of ddr4
3200 cl 14 memory the latest drivers
available at the time of testing have
been used
so let's get into the results for these
custom aib reviews i don't bother with
many game tests
we already have all that data from our
day one coverage so we're just going to
have a quick look at out of the box
performance along with the manual
overclock in
shadow of the tomb raider at 1440p we're
looking at a mere 3
performance improvement for the nitro
plus over the amd reference card
while i was able to squeeze a further
three percent from it with a manual
overclock
the gains at 4k are a little more
impressive here the nitro plus was five
percent faster than the amd reference
model out of the box
and then 10 faster with my overclock
that's not really an amazing performance
improvement but it was enough to match
the stock rtx 3080
when it comes to power consumption the
sapphire nitro plus is
certainly tuned more aggressively than
the amd reference model as power
consumption
has increased by 13 my manual overclock
increased power usage by a further eight
percent
and now we're above what the rtx 3090
founders edition sucks down
the stock operating temperatures of the
sapphire nitro plus are very impressive
especially given that amd did set a
rather high bar
here we're looking at a 2 degree
reduction for the gpu and gdr6 memory
so not an amazing improvement but again
given how good the reference model was
any improvement is quite impressive then
when it comes to vrm temps we are
looking at a six degree reduction which
is quite significant
though again both models do maintain a
very cool vrm temperature
that's well within spec finally here's a
quick look at noise
normalized operating temperatures though
please note we're not power normalizing
the cars as i feel that's
potentially one step too far making it
more of a scientific test
and less practical consumer advice the
big advantage of the nitro plus is its
increased power target
going beyond what can be achieved with
the reference models so it's unlikely
you'll be dialing it back for even lower
thermals but it's possible you will want
to tweak the fan curve
so when noise normalized there is
virtually no temperature difference
between these two models
which is an impressive result for the
nitro plus given it's handling
13 more power it is clearly the superior
design
though not by much the sapphire rx 6800
xt nitro plus is really everything i've
come to expect from a nitro plus
graphics card
it's cool it's quiet and it offers a
good amount of oc headroom
at least when compared to the amd
reference model
speaking of the reference model despite
amd for the first time
ever setting the bar very high this
wasn't a problem for sapphire as they
managed to match the thermals while
offering superior out of the box
performance
this achievement is made all the more
impressive when you realize that they've
accomplished this with a design that's
much lighter
and therefore a bit easier on your pcie
slot
actually the main advantage to shaving
off the extra weight is the reduced pcb
flex something we've seen quite a lot of
recently with the monstrous rtx 3080 and
3090 graphics cards
excessive weight also makes it more
challenging to mount the cooler to the
gpu die
something asus has had trouble with in
the past most notably with their strix
5700 xt
so in terms of performance the nitro
plus is excellent
whether or not it's the best 6800 xt is
yet to be seen
but it is certainly good enough to
recommend at this point in time though
it is the first and only custom aib 6800
xt graphics card that we've reviewed
but on here for testing i do have the
power color red devil
so we'll look at that shortly i also
have the red dragon on the way
along with some models from xfx and of
course there will be more as well
so many more 6800 series reviews to come
now key reasons to purchase the nitro
plus over the reference model include
the dual bar support
and increased overclocking headroom
other reasons might include stuff like
the physical design
perhaps you like the look of the nitro
plus better or maybe it's the rgb
effects that you like
more personally i do prefer the
construction of the reference card
being that it's all aluminium and while
that certainly is a nice luxury i feel
for most of you the dual bar support and
improved overclocking will be enough to
sway you towards the nitro
plus there is of course one last
rather important detail the price and
unlike the amd reference model which
targets the msrp
the nitro plus will certainly be
fetching a premium unfortunately at this
point in time
sapphire hasn't been able to tell me
what that premium is i've asked multiple
times
and they weren't able to tell me in time
for shooting this review so if i do have
that information
i will pin it as a comment below but
given what we saw with the 5700 xt
version that came in 60
us over the msrp so i'd estimate that
the 6800xt nitro plus will cost you at
least
700 us if not a little bit over 700
u.s so that's rtx 3080 money but of
course you can't buy one of those right
now and probably won't be able to for at
least
the next few months hopefully we're not
going to see the same thing with the
6800 xt
i am crossing my fingers for good
availability in three to four weeks time
but i'm certainly not going to hold my
breath but i am happy to cross my
fingers
i guess right now talking about the
price doesn't really matter which
is a bit of an unfortunate situation
given the price really should be
everything
anyway that is going to do it for this
one if you liked this video
you know what to do you can also
subscribe for more content as i said we
have a lot more
6800 xt and 6800 aib card reviews coming
there's also some new
nvidia geforce reviews coming on the
channel shortly so
if you're interested in that also make
sure you're subscribed you can also
join us over on floatplane or patreon if
you'd like to become a harbor unbox
community member
it will get you access to our exclusive
discord chat where you can talk with two
and myself and the rest of the
awesome harbor and box community we also
do a live stream at least once a month
again tim and myself
do that and we answer your questions
directly live and chat about current
events
also behind the scenes videos they're
worth checking out if you're interested
uh q and a's anyway if you're interested
link for all that stuff is in the video
description
if not perfectly fine and i would like
to just thank you for watching this
video
i'm your host steve and i'll see you
again next time
[Music]
you